make sure you guys hit the subscribe
button if you guys are enjoying the
content that we're throwing up
and uh make sure you guys hit the like
button if you enjoy the video and yeah
let's begin what's going on guys this is
rob and we
are uh we're gonna perform an experiment
here we're gonna perform a test um we
are going to cover the first part of the
origin of the teenage mutant ninja
turtles or at least the new origin from
idw's 2012 run which as far as i'm aware
is the current run right it's still
ongoing at this point i think it's like
110 issues or something like that but
we're going to conduct an experiment
here and the reason why is because this
is the nature of being a youtuber i get
this question all the time
like i want to start a youtube channel
what do i do one of the core aspects of
being a youtuber
is to understand your analytics right
and to look at your your what your fan
base wants you can look at your comments
but the issue you have with comments is
only a very very small percentage of
your fan base will ever actually comment
on a video right like that video that we
did
on the last ronin has like 110 000 views
right but like
1800 people commented and so at the end
of the day if of those 1800 people
a thousand want to see more ninja turtle
stuff but we can't make a youtube video
based on that right i mean we could but
it wouldn't really be beneficial for
like continuing to grow the channel and
so the only way to really know what it
is that people want is to one experiment
like this and then two to follow up by
looking at analytics right does the
video perform well are people watching a
lot of it that's the test
right that's the nature of what it means
to be a youtuber it's one part listening
to your fans and then one part listening
to the fans who don't actually say
anything right and just going by what
your youtube analytics say so what we're
doing here is again as far as i'm aware
i've done some research that i could be
wrong but i don't think i am as far as
i'm aware idw
basically restarted the ninja turtles
run in 2012 with this particular story
and the idea is that this is kind of
going this sort of jumps back and forth
between the past and the present we're
not going to do that instead what we're
going to do is kind of focus on past
events
and then sort of bookend into what's
going on in the current moment because
one leads directly to the other and so
what we end up doing here is basically
picking up about 18 months before the
present day
at the time this story was being written
but what you have here are a couple
different people
you've got april o'neil and you've got a
guy named chet really chet allen who
looks like
is what his name is for those people who
are really familiar with ninja turtles
that might ring a bell for you for me it
doesn't right it doesn't really seem
particularly uh important here but
the thing that matters is that what
they're doing is they're conducting a
bit of an experiment
involving a couple of different or
really a few different animals right one
comes in the form of a rat
and the other comes in the form of
turtles now the reason why this
experiment is being conducted really
comes by way
of a guy by the name of dr stockman
himself right he's talking directly to a
guy named general crane or at least you
know talking over the phone but it's
still a direct conversation and the idea
is that general crane has basically
provided
stockman with a kind of mutagen and
using that along with their own
resources that what stockman's looking
to do is seemingly try to develop super
soldiers while at the same time
use animals in the process and what
they're doing here is they're kind of
looking at the progress of this
experiment which comes in the form of
what's called terrapin
human bioarmor synthesis and then
rodentia psychotropic serum and so
effectively it's one experiment on the
turtles and then one experiment on the
rat itself
and the experiment for the most part
seems to be progressing insofar as they
don't really seem to have like a
measurable
determination of whether or not this rat
is able to develop uh developed
sentience but at the same time they
haven't died so the fact that they
haven't died is a good thing and then
it's just a matter of kind of
controlling the experiment a bit to see
what sort of see how things essentially
go from here but the explanation for
this really comes by way of a woman
named lindsay now april
o'neil for her part is really just seems
like the new girl here right she really
just kind of seems to be the new person
who's really more enamored with the the
animals themselves more so than the
experiments but doesn't really seem to
fully understand the experiment and so
when she asked the question of lindsay
what's going on with all this like the
ninja turtles
these little turtles are adorable the
rat's not very attractive lindsay
answered the question and basically
saying that the rat himself is part of
the psychotropic drug test where they're
trying to essentially
split the rat's consciousness right
split its mindset between its animal
instinct and its ability to achieve
sentience to have human level cognition
and seemingly the idea here seems to be
to build on its human level cognition to
essentially turn into a walking talking
rat right that more or less seems to be
the case so this obviously is splinter
right this is obviously like like the
origin of splinter himself and so from
there what you end up doing is picking
up kind of over periods of time where
you sort of jump ahead three months
later different things like that and you
end up finding out that what april had
done is she had actually
named the turtles the rat's name is
already splinter right that's right
the name of the rat and the reason why
they call that is literally because of
what they're trying to do right splint
the way a split the way and which its
mind works right created like a splinter
and it's its ability to be
you know to develop cognitive abilities
versus its animal instincts right so it
already has its name but for the turtles
themselves because of the fact that
april basically majored or at least has
a history
of renaissance uh 101 this semester at
least the semester she's in school she
ends up naming them after
you know renaissance art right
renaissance painters so you've got
leonardo donatello michelangelo and of
course raphael
and raphael's established as the guy
who's a little bit feisty which kind of
makes sense raphael's a dick here's a
here's the thing about raphael right the
guy's kind of a jerk
but at the end of the day man raphael's
got it where it counts
and that's the funny thing right that's
the funny thing about the ninja turtles
right
that's that's the important thing about
these ninja turtle guys right if i
here's the thing if i had to team up
with one ninja turtle it would be
raphael
leonardo is cool but he's too by the
books right he's too like well you know
we gotta follow the splinter and you
know what's what he wants us to do and
he'll do the right thing
and and michelangelo's uh like he's cool
to hang out with i would get beers with
michelangelo
because like he's he's he looks fun and
like the problem with donatello is like
he's too
techy but he's like the mkbhd of like
the ninja turtles world right let's
that's what he's like the marquis
brownlee of ninja turtles so it's kind
of like okay i wanna hang out with
raphael
because raphael's just he's just he's
just the guy right like he's just
the guy here's my question for you guys
who like if you could hang out
with one ninja turtle which one would it
be that's my question for you guys but
nonetheless
the fact that higher level thinking
within splinter because you know kind of
was achieved really comes by way of the
fact that while april o'neil is inside
the building sort of doing her thing
that splinter comes running up on her
essentially with a cd and this has all
the information of what's going on there
right this confidential property
the experiment that's being done on the
turtles right human exo armor synthesis
the experiment being done on splinter
himself how it can be applied to
military battle and strategy right so
they're essentially looking to take this
uh
this this research and weaponize it this
comes to comes to bear one when he does
that and two when she's met by the
arrival of what are basically ninjas or
they look like foot clan members right
and when they show up here of course
their goal is to one take the research
and then two to take the animals or at
least similarly just kind of take the
animals and so of course the disc is
destroyed in the attack and then they
immediately go after
uh the the mutagen basically the the
substances and they go after the animals
but splinter himself
realizing what's going on goes and pulls
the fire alarm right which is a genius
maneuver because what it'll do is it'll
bring the authorities right it'll bring
cops it'll bring the police department
and realizing these guys will realize
that themselves that basically the whole
process kind of gets hurt right so they
end up snatching up the ninja turtles
they don't
really snatch up the turtles themselves
they throw them in a bag and in turn of
course
splinter is still kind of kind of
sitting around there and when the cops
show up then of course the guys
have basically taken off by then now of
course splinter for his part chases
after these guys
right like literally hunts these guys
down and that's kind of a cool thing man
they were not prepared like nobody's
prepared for a rat right that's like
sentient but it's what makes splinter so
cool
is despite his small size and despite
the fact that he really is just a rodent
that weighs a couple pounds if that he
gets the upper hand on these guys right
he goes running up on one of these guys
claws the hell out of him they drop the
bag right they end up like throwing the
rat out of the way and the bag goes
crashing down onto the ground and
splinter falls alongside it but he's
exposed to the mutagen and the chemicals
and substances
all basically crack right like literally
the turtles themselves and everything
are all kind of exposed to this
this substance of sorts and so as a
result of that you have a cat that ends
up stumbling across this
and actually ends up taking one of the
turtles with the intention of consuming
it and so seeing what's going
on of course like you know rats and cats
are basically like mortal enemies
splinters like now son we ain't having
any of that right like you're not making
off with
you're not making off with my turtle
it's a little weird to see a
see a rat kind of guarding his turtles
in such a way probably because they're
so helpless but like a kind of knock
down drag out fight goes on between
these two and this is kind of cool the
cat of course ends up scratching the
hell out of
out of splinter and then basically
making off with the turtle splinter
continues to go on
and try to fight right tries to fight on
behalf of getting his turtle back but at
the end of the day
one of the turtles is just kind of left
behind right like this this turtle that
fell
is seemingly left behind here and the
reason why is because one we don't
really see what happens to it when
splinter when the when the cat basically
ends up taking off after splinter gets
in that eye you know after f splinter
dots that i
right and like takes it takes it away
from him and sends that cat fleeing for
his life
but the other thing is that really only
three turtles seem to be
inside this bag right and we know that
because of the fact that when the ninja
is basically track down or at least come
back down
uh to try to try to attain splinter and
the the bag of course filled with the
turtles that they end up falling out
splinter ends up dragging him into a
into a manhole into a sewer drain and
only three turtles fall down with him
right so it's splinter and these three
turtles and that's it now of course this
leaves lisa splinter passing out
it leads to the turtles you know looking
like they're kind of awake i don't know
it's kind of hard to tell when it's
turtles but
you end up having the the cat who seems
to have seen all of this
and so some some period later we're not
really given a definitive time frame
right we're not really giving an
instance where it's like four hours
later
splinter basically comes to and when he
does he's able to walk upright and he's
able to speak english
and so this basically means that he that
this goal has been achieved that
splinter himself has achieved higher
level reasoning now there is a lot more
going on to splinter than what we're
initially told here
and that's one of the important things
to understand is that it's not something
as simple as like splinter became
sentient and now he
somehow knows martial arts because you
know when you gain sentience you learn
martial arts especially when you're a
rat and you teach it to turtles there's
a little bit more going on
with regards to splinter here but when
he comes to he basically ends up looking
around he's like one of them is like
what happened and it's like he's like
what in the world is like my turtles
they're like yeah man
we're turtles and like this is the first
part
of the origin of teenage mutant ninja
turtles now here's a cool thing i'm
gonna throw this out here
before i finish this video ninja turtles
is legit
like i never i didn't really think it
was i was sitting here like okay so like
the last ronin did really well and the
last run is kind of a cool story like i
can get behind this story it's really
interesting i dig this uh but i was like
i don't know if like the t
the 2012 run is gonna be any good but i
was like you know what we'll read it
we'll buy it on comixology we'll read it
and uh here's the thing man
dude it's it's amazing i never realized
ninja turtles like ninja turtle comics
were this good man
i wish someone had told me before but
ninja turtles is amazing like it's
really really good so with that being
said guys we're gonna bring this video
to an end
if you are new here to comments explain
make sure you guys hit the sub button to
become part of the rob core if you guys
enjoyed this video make sure you drop
a like and i will catch you all later
peace
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
so
[Music]
you